et de bagdad à moscou la plupart des
personnes interrogées sur ces images ont
condamné l'essai de violences qui ont eu
lieu à washington écouter ce qu'il s'est
passé hier au congrès américain est une
émanation total de la démocratie ils
prétendent qu'ils ont la démocratie pour
leur propre peuple mais j'appellerai
cela une fausse démocratie parce qu'elle
n'existe pas et qu'elle est tout à fait
artificielle
ils essaient seulement de donner une
image déformée des pays arabes en disant
que ceux ci ne sont ni développé ni
organisé je regardais ça hier soir comme
tous les états lien partout dans le
monde
j'ai vu ces images terribles que
personne ne s'attendait à voir sur la
colline du capitole à washington
et puis entendre l'actuel président des
états unis
qualifié ces gens de spéciaux est tout
aussi grave parce que c'est lui qui les
a encouragés et ensuite les a presque
défendu pour moi c'est un pays dingue
donc
c'est dans l'ordre des choses ils sont
un peu dingue et ils réagissent de façon
excessive
dans tous les cas de figure d'une
manière générale trump et un excessif
pourquoi
on peut redouter jusqu'à quel point ça
peut aller qu'en des populistes arrivent
au pouvoir ils font de telles choses et
oui cela ne devrait jamais arriver
vous savez qu aux etats unis la
démocratie a une longue histoire et
quand on arrive à quelque chose comme ça
oui on a peur cela a l'air assez
ridicule il faut savoir reconnaître sa
défaite à temps il se comporte comme un
rat qui est expulsé de la maison et il
revient